what excited me the most about playing  morbius was the fact that he's never  been on screen before i've become  something  different  i had the opportunity to bring this  character to life that has never been  seen quite like this imagine being  somebody who just wants more time i  should have died years ago why am i  still here if not to fix this someone  who uses their brilliance to hunt for a  cure for a rare blood disorder that  threatens to shorten people's lives i  was trying to help people and instead  finding something completely beyond your  wildest dreams  or nightmares  unable to control his newfound powers  and thirst for blood  dr michael morbius becomes the monster  that now resides within  [Music]  see you in theaters  [Music]  you